okay I want to have an adult
conversation with you about whether
strategically it is time for Bernie
Sanders to start attacking Elizabeth
Warren hard if he wants to maintain a
shot at securing the Democratic
nomination now stop delete that email
draft you've already opened to me where
you're about to rip me a new one I want
to be really clear here this is a
strategic conversation I'm against toxic
Democratic infighting I believe that we
need to be running good issue-based
campaigns but it has now been brought up
to me several times and I want to
address it on the facts to answer the
question what can Bernie do to get back
in this race we just looked at polling
data the polling data is not looking
good for Bernie particularly over the
last couple of weeks Elizabeth Warren
has taken a lead in an average of recent
polls and is trending she is now
nationally the front-runner or you could
say Co frontrunner with Joe Biden Bernie
Sanders had a heart procedure he's been
off the trail for a little bit he's
getting back to it but it has hurt his
poll numbers I wish it were different
but this is the reality that we're
dealing with and so I started seeing
messages like for example on our
subreddit where user Wiesn as posted
about this who said from start to
present the Sanders campaign hasn't gone
after Warren I think this has been a
smart move allowing them to be harder on
more conservative candidates however it
is my belief that the time is now for
Sanders to go on the offense here is my
case only three candidates remain in
double-digit polling no one else has a
chance
number two Bernie just had heart surgery
he needs to retake control of the race
number three Bernie's polling has been
leveling off he needs to take out Warren
and get her supporters number four he
raised more than anyone else in the
third quarter of the year he has a
strong following and number 5 Warren has
been given way too much easy airtime and
she isn't left enough she won't make the
changes that Bernie will I think
Warren's presence has been a benefit for
the country but now she needs to go so
here's what you have to understand this
is a strategic analysis
imagine that Bernie doesn't go after
Warren right say Bernie doesn't take the
advice from wiesen ass and says I'm not
gonna attack Warren that's not been my
strategy I'm not gonna do it he goes
into his next debate and he attacks Joe
Biden who he is very different from the
problem is that any damage Bernie is
able to do to Joe Biden helps Elizabeth
Warren as much as it helps him why do I
say that because mathematically that's
the reality if you look at second
choices for Biden voters 30% of Biden
voters would switch to Warren if they
abandoned Joe Biden and 25% of Biden
voters would switch to Bernie what this
means is that when Biden loses support
when a Biden supporter sees Bernie
destroy Biden on the stage they are
marginally more likely to switch their
vote from Biden to Warren than from
Biden to Bernie mathematically that
means that going after Biden is not
particularly useful to Bernie Sanders by
successfully attacking Biden by making
him look really bad Bernie is helping
Warren at least as much as he helps
himself there's a mathematical reality
so this is an important question is
there a path to the nomination for
Bernie to get from the 14/15 he's
polling on average right now to get into
the lead that does not require taking
support from Elizabeth Warren in the
most primitive mathematical sense yes
all of the other candidates if you take
out from the hundred percent right now
you take out Biden support and Warren
support and Bernie support everybody
else like Buddha judge or Rorick
everybody they have a total of 22
percent support there's little slices
Buddha judge has 5.6
Andrew yang is 2.8 Tulsi Gabbard has 0.8
altogether that's 22% but Bernie can't
get that full 22% right even if he
obliterates every other candidate it
makes everybody say I need to abandon
all of these people Bernie is only the
preferred second option for a slice of
those candidates so imagine that Bernie
so brutally destroys and embarrasses
Buddha judge that every Buddha judge
supporter says
I'm going to my second choice buddha
judge supporters prefer Warren over
Bernie
same thing with Kamala Harris Harris
supporters prefer Warren over Bernie so
I hate this I looked at this every which
way last night and this morning but
mathematically I don't see a way for
Bernie to win without taking support
directly from Elizabeth Warren which is
tough because Elizabeth Warren
supporters marginally prefer Biden over
Bernie okay I don't want to see it I
don't want to see this get ugly there
may be intangible collateral damage that
a really ugly showdown between Bernie
and Warren could do to the eventual
candidate but I know that there are
people in my audience who do want to see
it and believe that any cost to get
Bernie the nomination over Warren is
worth it now of course it's not even
this simple because there's also the
issue of whether the people who would
vote for Bernie would be convinced to do
it by seeing him attack Elizabeth Warren
that may actually turn voters off and
it's not been Bernie's strategy it could
be anathema to the way that he has run
his campaign so my question to you today
is we're being adults here I'm not
suggesting anyone do anything I'm just
telling you what the math says reply in
the comments if you're watching are you
on youtube or send me a tweet at D
Pakman is there a way for Bernie Sanders
to get back in control here without
going directly after Elizabeth Warren
okay you're listening let me know on
Twitter at D Pakman let me know down in
the comments and I will remind you this
weekend we have a major major membership
drive we have not done this for about a
year we are going to be doing a one-day
massive membership discount if you've
been thinking about becoming a supporter
of the David Pakman show get on our
mailing list at david pakman.com sign up
for it this weekend you will get an
email it'll be called something like the
email you've been waiting for it will
have a code that will work just on one
day maybe it'll work both weekend days
just because maybe people need an extra
day but it'll be a weekend only special
the biggest discount of the year I would
love to have your support
to be notified of it just get on our
mailing list